hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan where I
answer your questions today I'm going to
be talking about what courses you should
take in university or in school to help
you prepare to be an entrepreneur so
today's question comes from Martha we
wrote in asking Evan I'm consuming a
bachelor's degree in procurement Supply
Management heading to my second year in
August as an entrepreneur can you please
advise me on another course I can do
alongside dine order to be skilled so
thank you for the question Martha a
great question one that I get a lot from
young entrepreneurs who are in school or
starting school because they want to
start their own business and hoping to
use their education to help them as much
as possible from my own experience is
kind of all I can share with you i watch
the University of Toronto and
unfortunately there weren't too many
courses that would help me with my
entrepreneurship skills there was one
course in small business management so
if there is anything that that is about
entrepreneurship or small business you
definitely want to take that on what
else I would look at is try to find
something related to marketing finance
accounting those might give you some of
the hard skills that you need to run
your business but what I would do is try
to connect with some of the clubs that
happen at the university I think that
the the greatest experience that I got
out of the university was being able to
find people who also were interested in
entrepreneurship and we actually started
our own first business out of university
so I was running my company while taking
classes in university so trying to find
like-minded people see if there's an
entrepreneur Club or small business club
that you can join up with or if there's
any seminars or events because these
people you know they're they'll give you
some ideas and advice but also could
become lifelong friends and business
partners as you continue to to grow up
you know and as these people graduate
and start their own businesses you have
people you can potentially connect to
and rely on down the line so I try to
think beyond just the courses and also
try to connect with the community of
entrepreneurs around you if your
eventual goal is to start your own
business I'd also look at potentially
starting up
partnering with an existing company and
taking on a part-time job so find a
company who is doing exactly what you
want to do smaller companies somebody
who's either a solo entrepreneur or has
a few employees but not not a big
company and try to learn as much as you
can about their business how they got
started all the operations you know
entrepreneurs always need help so if you
can prove to be a valuable resource for
them
then that can start giving you some
ideas and how they run their business
and give you some thoughts as well as if
this is the type of business you want to
run or not a lot of times we have ideas
for businesses but once we get into it
that is a terrible idea
so being paid by somebody to learn is a
great opportunity to in a low-risk way
learn about the industry find out if
it's for you gain some skills and that
can be in addition to doing your regular
university coursework one final
suggestion is helping that really helped
me with my university career is I was
starting my business while I was at
university I was in third year I believe
and what I actually did was I talked to
one of my marketing professors and
created my own course with him so I
don't know if this is an option at your
University or not but we were able to do
it at University of Toronto where I
created my own course and with with this
professor he basically gave me a credit
so we didn't have an exam what we had to
kind of come together and figure out how
we get how I was gonna you know what the
course is gonna be about housings in my
research what findings I was gonna
create and I basically made the course
about my business and I was able to run
my business get his advice and also get
a credit for it so you have to talk to
you know professors they have to know
your they have to be willing to mentor
you for the semester people to give you
that credit but it's another opportunity
to potentially use your university or
school education to be able to get you
know more out of it to help you build
your business so one look for any
entrepreneur small business courses if
they don't exist look for anything that
might give you some hard skills
marketing finance accounting any of
those kind of courses to trying to get
involved again in the university
community look at clubs that you might
be able to join or any events or
seminars that are happening and through
see if you might be able to create your
own course with a professor
around the topic that is interesting
that can help you launch your business
and then for also again look to see if
you might be able to get a part-time job
outside of the University where you can
learn from an entrepreneur and also gain
the skills that you need when you are
ready to launch your own business so
hopefully that helped Martha a great
question I love answering that and love
helping young entrepreneurs for those of
you watching if you like the video
please give it a thumbs up below what
makes you want to do more of these
videos for you guys and if you have any
advice to Martha or you have a question
of your own feel free to leave in the
comments below I always read the
comments and I love reading the comments
that it always makes my day so please
leave a comment if you can
and we'll see you on the next episode
you